et on en parle avec nadia seraiocco qui
est chargé de cours à l'école des médias
du calme bonjour madame seraiocco
bonjour bonjour monsieur pour qu on va
commencer tout d'abord par le début on
reproche à ces géants du web de quoi
trop gros trop 2001 de détruire
carrément la compétition mais en fait
les reproches sur tout ce qui touche à
la concurrence cet antre autant qu'ils
ont intégré peu à peu près toute la
compétition qui était là dans leur
domaine ils sont allés chercher son
pense à facebook sont approchés
instagram est allé chercher watsa mais
bien d'autres aussi entreprises qu'ils
intègrent souvent et parfois ce qu'on
fait le les dissoudre dans leur
organisation
d'ailleurs il ya des courriels acquis
dans le fil de l'audition qui
aujourd'hui fait au congrès ont été
révélés à ce propos le qui disait que
quand on avait regardé comment ils
comment justement à reprendre instagram
c'était on le prend un pion n'utilise
tout les moyens sociaux qu'ils ont
développées pour augmenter notre propre
populaire dépit faire grandir notre
entreprise c'est que c'est beaucoup ça
fait partie des choses qui leur sont
reprochés si on parle d'apple et de
google on va penser aussi à leur
boutique d'applications qui dans les
deux corps un des fonds ont été utilisés
pour ralentir la compétition a pour seul
effet reproché souvent par exemple de
pro faire les mises à jour de spotify
parce que spotify comme je te vois comme
un applications de musique en continu
leur faisait compétition avec un pot
music fait qu'ils aient toutes sortes de
choses comme ça de pratiques qui disons
sont un peu discutable dans le milieu
des affaires
donc lorsque les deux nouveaux joueurs
c'est ce qu'on fait on compte entre ou
de les bloquer oui on en a fait
l'acquisition vous l'avez dit notamment
donc avait avec facebook c'est la même
chose d'aussi power girl mais j'aimerais
aussi qu'on prenne un autre exemple le
commerçant en ligne
la livraison à domicile est ce qui est
possible actuellement de s'implanter ou
tout de suite amazon va vous pousser sur
les lignes de côtés m'a écouté c'est
très difficile de s'implanter parce
qu'essayer de battre livré 124 d'amazon
qui vaille
quand on est dans les pires moments
réussissent convaincant dans des délais
très rapides à livrer et on va remarquer
aussi que présentement ce qui montre que
la compétition un peu baissé j'aiderai
les bras devant amazon c'est par exemple
ce bail etc vont utiliser le service de
livraison site d'amazon vont commencer à
ses yeux des justement l'heure
service avec ces compagnies là est de
plus en plus de compagnies canadiennes
vont aller se faire des boutiques un
vont faire leurs ventes à travers des
sites comme amazon parce que sinon ils
ont l'impression qu'ils ne seront pas vu
parce que c'est toujours l'autre les
gens vont en premier
et si vous cherchez dans google quelque
chose vous allez voir ce que google
offre parce que amazon offre vous allez
pas avoir un corps frêle rien savoir de
la mise en jeu commence à se démarquer
club parce que eux c'est eux qui ont le
plus grand pouvoir notre garçon tel clip
des fonds votre saga femme par microsoft
bat comme jamais mais pas leur en ce
moment dans ce procès s'ils y ont eu
dans leur bon moment deux procès aux
autos s'il a du chien je voudrais mais
donc ce qu'on va remarquer c'est
qu'entre ils se font des faveurs faites
là on est devant 4
cheetah je dois même pugilat convergence
entre ces quatre exercices
oui c'est comme s'il ne se nuisent pas
assez comme vous imaginez la suite on
les 400 à faire ces personnes qui va
abattre au long parce que les trois
hommes vont être pris avec donc tout le
monde se regarde comme ça amazon a su de
la pub sur facebook facebook livre des
listes à bazzo moyennant de l'argent
s'est aperçu même que pendant qu'il y
avait accédé fois nos courriels en ce
moment messenger
ensuite google bien fait des démarches
et aussi avec facebook c'est tout
doucement avec amazon ou encore ils ont
chacun est également aussi tout à fait
la chose donc l on peut développer des
synergies
le monde est complètement dépendant ou
50 tout seul oui oui j'ai aussi posé la
question inattendue sont aujourd'hui les
gens tendaient notamment google
à la question aussi c'est celle ci est
ce que les gros jouable complètement
l'innovation à l'heure actuelle où est
ce que leur plateforme également peuvent
aider les plus petites entreprises à
fleuriste un peu ça qu'on attendait
aussi comme je crois que oui il ya un
peu des deux mais la question est que 14
cas pas de transparence sauf comment ils
font ces choses-là sur les achats
communs et les gens quand ils font des
rechutes compagnie ils ont peu été très
transparent jusqu'à maintenant quand il
est temps facebook a racheté whatsapp
s'est engagé auprès de la commission
européenne le sommet à la concurrence
puis pour auprès du bureau du
commissaire à la concurrence de ne pas
dissoudre justement d'entreprise dans
l'art de garder des scénarii sa poche sa
tenue
un à peu près cette promesse là quand
c'est fait c'est fait un statut qu'il
joue comme ils veulent et dans certains
cas oui vous pouvez dire que vous pouvez
utiliser
c'est clair que des gens au canada qui
réussissent à tirer leur épingle du jeu
grâce à amazon
il y avait énormément de cette même de
commerces québécois qui sont hébergés
par amazon web services aws c'est clair
vous posterez sauf que tokyo peau de
transparence dont on peut voir des corps
par exemple de compagnie qui offrait des
services va pas des services des biens
sur amazon et amazon qu'est-ce qu'ils
font bailly regarde qui offre on peut
s'en trouver une ou des produits comme
ceux moins cher fait qu'on va on va nous
mêmes comme ansaldo frais et finalement
ils font fermer matière ces petites
entreprises avec les y'a vraiment il ya
des collaborations qui est la fabrique
est pas toujours là parce que leur but
ils font des joutes 200 milliards de
l'amazone facebook c'est dans les 80
quelques milliards par année de profit
leur but est toujours à l 100 en bourse
leur but c'est toujours de montrer plus
de profits aux actionnaires
et oui depuis début de la pandémie
d'ailleurs je regardais pour amazon ça
va produire 110 9 pour 100 g également
aussi devant un congrès c'est la
question de démanteler et des élus qui
aimeraient bien quand il se démanteler
ces géants du web ça s'est déjà vu parce
que c'était dans les années 10 mais ça
fait très très loin ce qu'on voit la
même chose maintenant
non on en parle et pieds des gens qui
émettent là dessus un des plans complets
ou est-ce qu'on s'imagine que facebook
devient par exemple une entreprise avec
une partie publique inventive et cetera
ou encore condé fait google dans ses
différentes composantes
mais tel que je dirais l'entreprise
américaine est vue en ce moment ça va
être très difficile de mettre ça en
force parce que je peux pas imaginer
même que les gouvernants qui ont besoin
de ces machines là pour les élections
pour le thriller publicité pour
rejoindre des citoyens vont mettre la
hache dedans aussi facilement fait que
je pense que si les choses restent
nécessaires fallait faire énormément on
l'a vu avec l'élection de 2006 aux états
unis et je pense que donc ça va être
fait il va ils vont marcher sur des
oeufs quand ils vont demander des choses
et ils vont espérer qu'on remporte un
petit peu leur demande pour ne pas être
obligé
je pense de refaire un exercice de
demain comme le présent de distance en
ce moment là peut-être davantage aussi
de régulation merci beaucoup nadia
seraiocco d'abord été avec nous